[Música]
bueno pues de la mora
jajajaja
y bueno fíjense que por alguna razón
desde para mi vida siempre me preguntaba
así como cosas filosofales que hago aquí
no sabe qué hago aquí en el mundo que
hago cuál es mi destino no qué hago aquí
en este escenario por ejemplo
cuando caí en los fosos de la
gastronomía al principio pues no fue
diferente me preguntan muchas cosas y
estando en la escuela de gastronomía me
preguntaba bueno y yo qué hago aquí no
vamos a empezar pues qué es la
gastronomía y cuál es su finalidad no
porque existe no
y
la primera no fue tan complicada porque
yo dije bueno gastronomía es todo
aquello que ha nutrido al hombre desde
siempre
nada más que en la finalidad ahí se
tenía un poquito de dificultades y en
eso pues empecé a preguntar a mis
compañeros y les decía oye y para ti qué
es la gastronomía y ellos por lo general
me respondían cosas como que la
gastronomía con finalidad ser el arte
que enamora los sentidos y estar a la
vanguardia y ser la tendencia y
cualquier paráfrasis de esto no lo cual
a mí me parecía un poco sesgado o sea
decía bueno sin cierto eso es una parte
no pero la gastronomía es muchísimo más
que eso no la gastronomía es universal y
la gastronomía es eso que dices y
también es la tortilla y también es la
humilde sopa que ha alimentado la
población por años y todo eso es
gastronomía también y en tu finalidad no
lo incluyes no entonces seguir pensando
un poco y
y en eso recordé un poquito los palos
filosos a todos éstos
camus en mi cabeza
y dije
por ahí entra la bola en la parranda
salió el post gratis y me dice mira
recuerda que la finalidad de la medicina
es erradicar las enfermedades y hacemos
y cierto que vaya que es un reto y dije
bueno y si la finalidad de la
gastronomía es erradicar el hambre
pregunte a mí mismo está bien ahí vamos
pero dejo ahora yo un poquito fuera a
ellos y digo bueno pero es lo que ellos
hablan también se podría entender como
hambre no es hambre de algo diferente es
hambre de algo innovador entonces se
podría decir que para mí llegué a una
conclusión la finalidad de la
gastronomía es erradicar el hambre de
todo tipo en su sentido textual y ese
sentido metafórico igual cuando llegue a
estas conclusiones no ya me sentía muy
dueño de la situación
y comencé a
a nuevos pensamientos y empecé a conocer
muchas personas de muchas partes del
mundo y los empecé a conocer a través de
su comida y sus duelos y sus alegrías
pues me sabían agridulces y sentí su
hambre el hambre de su pueblo a través
de la empatía y entonces conociendo
todas estas personas me di cuenta que
realmente somos iguales o sea no importa
el pueblo en el mundo somos todos
iguales y a mí me lo enseñó la
gastronomía y entonces dije bueno si la
gastronomía es universal y nosotros
pertenecemos a ese universo por lo tanto
la gastronomía es nuestra y no importa
si esa gastronomía es de lima o de india
no importa es mía me pertenece está en
este mundo inglés mía o sea no no sólo
es mexicana ella toda la gastronomía en
el mundo me pertenece
y con este nuevo pensamiento me volví a
investigar un poco la historia
a ver si me daba un poco la razón y
curiosamente sí por qué
me di cuenta que a través de la historia
era la diversidad de culturas después el
choque cultural y después la inclusión
lo que lo que básicamente dictaba la
historia la gastronomía no y así fue por
ejemplo cuando arabia llegó a italia a
través de sicilia llevando consigo el
arroz no eventualmente ambos dieron lo
que tenían en sus manos y eventualmente
se creó el risotto por ejemplo
y lo mismo pasó en españa se llegaron
del norte de áfrica y españa con arroz y
azafrán y eventualmente tuvieron la
paella no entonces así como esto
muchísimos platillos a través de la
historia en el mundo no son más que la
mezcla de culturas no y la inclusión y
abrazarnos todos nosotros rpc a nuestras
altas
y entonces
y entonces comencé a sentir lo sentí más
mío este pensamiento
y entonces
gente así y entonces todos estos
ingredientes a los que todas estas
personas tenían vamos a decir autóctono
totalmente y nos empezaron a compartirlo
y así debe de ser y sobre todo no lo
puedo creer ahora en este siglo en el
que estamos que pues básicamente es todo
hasta un clic de distancia no y la
tecnología ha avanzado tanto que si no
lo puedes hacer tú mismo lo pueden
mandar pedir y ya se explicó entonces
todos de todos y esos ingredientes
curiosamente creo que tienen que seguir
viajando así como en ese momento lo
hicieron eso simplemente tienen que
seguir viajando y así como en aquel
entonces llegaron a esos cocineros que
hicieron esos platillos clásicos de esas
cocinas tan tan grandes pues ahora
tienen que llegar a los a los brazos de
nuevos cocineros que tienen una nueva
visión que tienen otras especies
experiencias otras habilidades y tiene
que seguir evolucionando porque la
gastronomía tiene una evolución natural
de la mano del hombre
entonces lo más importante que yo quiero
hablar sobre la gastronomía el día de
hoy para ustedes es sobre diversidad y
de eso hasta la medicina nos nos apoya
no porque una dieta diversa donde tienes
diferentes fuentes de proteínas
diferentes fuentes de carbohidratos de
vitaminas y minerales
es bien sabido que es lo más sano que
puedes consumir no
y si bien entonces en la diversidad nos
nutre como personas no nos nutre en
cuerpo este y nos nutre culturalmente
bueno entonces yo yo me digo porque las
personas se privan de
de ser más incluyentes y abrirse más a
los nuevos sabores si explicó es como
como toda la vida cuando nos enamoramos
de ese primer platillo cuando estábamos
niños no lo puedes volver a revivir una
y otra vez con muchísimo aquellos que ni
siquiera te imaginas que no sabemos de
qué cocina es o si alguien mismo lo va a
crear no eso de eso es cocina italiana y
eso es comida español a esas etiquetas
no nos sirven de mucho si es vigo porque
agregamos decir anteriormente todo es
diverso todo es parte de una cultura y
acción y bueno mi invitación para
ustedes es de empezar a ver la
gastronomía un poco más abiertamente no
y no decir ser mexicano y consumo
gastronomía mexicana no no no no somos
ciudadanos del mundo y comemos
justamente eso y aprendemos de ellos a
través de la comida y a través de la
historia no
y bueno
justamente eso es lo que tratamos de
hacer en hermosillo con los proyectos
que tenemos nosotros
mis socios y yo siempre hemos pensado
que
hermosillo por ejemplo para ser un lugar
una segunda ciudad pequeña vamos a decir
donde tenemos son muy tradicionalistas
nosotros tratamos de tener cocinas del
norte de áfrica de tener comida marroquí
libanesa árabe tener otro lugar que
tenemos es de cocina de la india tenemos
otro lugar que es apoyamos la cerveza
artesanal entonces nosotros queremos
justo eso incomodar sacarlo de su zona
de confort pero es para todos es para
ser más incluyentes es para generar un
nuevo ambiente más abierto y
y más saludable no porque la dieta
diversa nos va a llevar a una mejor
salud
y bueno
creo que la invitación es a aventurarnos
sin prejuicios y abrirnos un poco a los
nuevos sabores a las nuevas ideas y a
los jóvenes que están haciendo
con los increíbles con las cocinas
vegetarianas y hay que dar la
oportunidad a todos y esa es la
invitación para ustedes el día de hoy
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]